hello everybody and welcome to episode
number four of my freet to-play flipping
challenge today we're starting at about
64 mil and we're going to see where we
can get to
today um mainly what we're going to be
trying to flip is the ring of nature
it's had a pretty good price recently
and seems to uh have a pretty big margin
pretty frequently uh we'll give that a
try we might try the Ring of coins as
well uh but I think the Ring of nature
seems to be a lot better all right uh
let's get started all right so first up
we're looking at the Ring of nature here
as you can see it looks like it could
even split between almost 700k as a
margin uh which is extremely good we'll
go ahead and maybe buy some of these for
about
9750 looking to sell them for 10.2 mil
maybe maybe a little less but either way
300K in profit is still extremely good
for free to play I will go ahead and
just dump all our money in these rings
of nature pretty well and yeah we'll
come back when they have sold
so unfortunately we left offer and for
quite a while and only one of them
managed to buy so we ended up selling it
for well I guess 150k profit which isn't
bad uh but it could have been a lot
better either way we didn't lose any
money uh but we're kind of back to the
drawing board here so I think we're
going to maybe put a smaller offer in
for the ring of nature uh cuz it is look
at that fluctuation 7.2 into 9 not sure
if I'm going to get mergin like that but
I think we readjust the price uh we
hopefully should be able to get a decent
margin we're going to try for 7501 we're
going to get some other items too uh but
mainly we're going to give this ringing
nature another shot we go for four of
them this time at about 30 mil in total
next up we're going to be looking at the
Ring of coins now this item historically
doesn't have as big a margin as ring of
Nature and it does cost more so I wasn't
uh really going for it at first uh but
200k margin is still decent and you can
see the price is fluctuating yeah about
200k so we'll go ahead and uh maybe buy
it cuz it is at a low up a low point
right now um we'll put it in for let's
see 14
312 yeah something like that if we buy
it we might be able to get a 300K margin
which would be good and we'll go
for and well we can't afford that many
we'll just go for two and we're having a
quick look at the Gilded chain body uh
this item has worked pretty well for us
a couple times uh we might to get like
100k margin on each at one point not
sure we can get that anymore more but it
looks like a 40 or 50k margin is still
possible uh which is pretty good for the
price point again this is free to play
so we have a little bit less to work
with here but we'll put an offering for
652 and that will go for about 10 of
them all right guys we'll come back when
they have sold all right there we go
guys we've got some really good flips
coming in right now uh the rings of
nature ended up selling for an insane
profit but we'll start with uh the Ring
of coins uh so the Ring of coins uh we
only sold for about 248k profit not
terrible but a lot of money invested
into that uh the guilded chain bodies
sold for a 41k profit on each one uh
nine of those gives us about
370k uh but the main winner here is ring
of nature 443k on each ring five rings
gives us 2.2 mil such a good profit for
free play so I'm definitely going to
give this another try uh but yeah rings
of nature really good so far all right
so we're 100% going to go and try this
item again we're going to open it up on
G tracker quickly here so the rings of
nature are in a constant state of
dropping now this is possible to flip
consistently but you have to be ahead of
the curve kind of uh you don't want to
get stuck with an item cuz it's
consistently going to be dropping uh so
we're going to put an offer in for about
7940 and uh we'll go
for and we'll go for five again maybe
and we'll go for four this time uh yeah
the Ring of nature is dropping but still
a good opportunity to flip it cuz if you
buy it uh really underdo your offer and
predict predicting what it's going to be
dropping to you can snag items for
really cheaply uh next up I think we're
going to try the team Cape zero it seems
to have a really good margin 200k it's
pretty good yeah this item seems to have
a
400k uh possible split just in the last
24 hours uh so we're definitely going to
give it a try uh now coming up is a bit
of an errror I obviously am recording
this afterwards uh but didn't realize at
the time I'm currently trying to buy the
team Cape X don't judge me too hard here
uh
God I don't know why I didn't realize
why this is so expensive so anyway I
instantly buy four of them and then I
realized oh [__] that is not the right
item uh so we go ahead and cancel it
hopefully we won't lose too much money
on this uh I should really get that out
of there now before someone else sells
it oh God come on okay we got it
canceled but uh yeah we figured that out
basically we're just going to try
dumping it back in for what we bought it
for which was about 1.9 mil or something
like that we'll have to go look up the
price of the team Cape X now I was not
planning on Flipping it but uh well we
don't have a choice at this point all
right so the team Kip x uh is well I
don't even know why we're looking it up
really we should just try dumping it
back for what we bought it for which is
about
$799 uh so it doesn't look like we
bought it for an unreasonably high price
which is good uh hopefully we can just
dump it for a net net loss of nothing or
uh slight gain maybe all right try
number two we're going to go ahead and
try to the team cap zero again now we're
trying to buy it for about uh 4 mil
pretty well so we'll go ahead try that
again 4030 and we'll just use the rest
of our money on this and we'll be able
to afford seven all right guys we'll
come back when these items have sold all
right guys we're back with another
really successful flip uh we'll start
with the team Cape zeros uh which we
ended up selling for 42.99 K and we
bought them for
403k so 269k in profit on that four of
those gives us just over a m but one 0
75k in profit which is really good uh
the team Cape X's we ended up selling
back right for that price insta bot four
so no loss on that which is pretty
awesome and the team or the um nature
Rings uh rings of nature sorry came in
again with about a 400k profit on each
one so five of those gives us near 2 mil
again uh so we're ending uh for today at
about 70.5 mil and uh I know this is a
really short episode but in con Junction
with me being really busy and the server
is just being awful and laggy and I know
I'm flipping but it's still challenging
to get offers in and the offers aren't
buying as much cuz people aren't on to
buy them or sell them to me so anyway I
hope you guys enjoyed the episode even
in three or four flips we ended up
getting pretty much 6 mil some really
successful flips rings of nature
definitely going to try those again uh
and maybe the rings of coin in the
future all right guys hope you enjoyed
the video and I will see you guys in the
next episode
[Music]